hello do you think there are going to be
any big changes once this pandemic's
over or we're just going to be like ah
that was a funny thing that happened
last year right i mean like in terms of
japan
like you know because we're already such
a yeah do you think japan's
never going to stop wearing masks now
like because before
you know it was still a socially
accepted norm for people to wear masks
but not everyone wore masks and now i
feel like
now it's going to be so deeply ingrained
in the culture that i feel like
90 to 80 of people are just going to be
permanently wearing masks oh yeah of
course
i mean you know like people already wear
masks here like you know during
especially this time of year when you're
like you know flu season
people have hay fever because you know
that kind of stuff and then you know you
have like the influenza season in like
of
november where people are getting sick
all the [ __ ] time yeah everyone's
wearing a mask and it's like
is your face a little bit cold wear a
mask you know do you know what i'm
hoping
and i think it's going to happen and i'm
happy for it
people are going to take care of the
hygiene during conventions that's
i am hopeful that a global pandemic will
make
nerds care more about the hygiene during
a big social gathering
am i feel you know what i feel if
anything it's going to be like
listen we we're all not going to get
each other sick now we've we've all
gotten the shot
yeah and and i've been and i've been
forced to use hand sanitizer and bathe
and wash my hands
for far too long i'm gonna go on a
bathing strike
i think i'd like to just see the like
the alcohol stay in front of like yeah
that's that's i think if more people
just especially at conventions where you
are
shaking hands with so many [ __ ]
people and you know
you know maybe wearing more masks in
convention that's that's that's not
exactly a bad thing
because conflu is just an accepted part
that is an accepted part of every
convention you go you go to right well
it's more like
see here's the one thing i've never
understood about conflue right like
right whenever you catch a cold
right it's usually from someone yeah
who's the [ __ ] who's going to a con
with a cold i mean there's loads of
people because i mean i get it right
like
if if they booked it yeah yeah you've
you've already taken
them off work you've already paid money
you've booked your hotel yeah but
they'll
get a coffee the least you can do is
like try and stay as hygienic as
possible right
which is why you're talking about no i
know
can we can we change this please like
that's that's what i'm saying
i'm i'm hoping that i go to the next
convention or maybe like not just the
next one because obviously the next
one's gonna be affected yeah but maybe
in like three years time we still got
the same etiquette of you know
if you know maybe wearing masks isn't
such a bad thing we're a master use hand
sanitizer
people having hand sanitizers just like
easily readily available like if i'm
just like
oh [ __ ] does anyone have any hand
sanitizer and like three people around
me just be like yeah bro i got you back
i think that's a positive change maybe
you know maybe the smell can change but
that's that's just hopeful thing
that that that is hopeful you can make
those ones that like [ __ ] wet your
hand to oblivion illegal you know the
ones when you get it and it's just like
uh oil has been dropped on your head
that [ __ ] should be illegal
where it's like way too sticky but it's
like sticky it's it's like feels like
it's been hydrated to like one thousand
percent like
it's weird why do they keep buying this
[ __ ] stop making that that's the potent
[ __ ] dude
is it really though i i i like the
feeling of that one because
your hands feel clean because it's like
that puts his hand in the tango one time
and now he wants to like have his
[ __ ]
groove all over him listen don't knock
it till you try it right because like
your finger in your tendon yeah
because like sometimes you get like you
go to a restaurant here and they're like
please please sanitize your channels and
they give you like this
they spray like the tiniest spray on and
you're like you're meant to like make
this tiny spray
last like like cover your entire absorbs
into your palm before you
stretch it out i'm just like you you
know that picture where it's like the
door that's being held by the cheeto and
like the swat team
breaking down the door that's what it
feels like when they put like that
piddly little spray on and you're like
okay i can see this does nothing but
you're just doing it because it's like
regulation yeah
like i don't want my hand been feel like
i've just dunked it in like a vat of oil
like that's what it feels like sometimes
i think i like the feeling of like
like it's one it covers your hands and
two you can feel it evaporate so you get
like a
little tingly cooling sensation i rather
than go overboard with the hand
sanitizer than on the board like i
i feel i feel like it's clean otherwise
it's it is [ __ ] it's like
i know there is my hands are the
cleanest it is sanitized that's that's
the point of hand sanitizing it [ __ ]
sanitizes your
that point zero one percent of germs is
clinging on for dear life on my hands
right now like i just prefer to use like
soap i don't know i like the feeling
you can't soak your hands up you're
going like a restaurant you can just be
like all right
spray a little bit on then i'm gonna go
toilet and clean my hands what what
takes so much more effort yeah but i
like that is the least
optimized thing yeah coming from a man
who optimizes everything in his life
restaurants aren't inherently an
unoptimized experience there's
so much waiting imagine imagine the
queue to the toilet yeah if that if that
was just
norm not everyone could be large brained
like myself you know
shut up [ __ ] just shut up all you have
to do is buy this gel
it sanitizes your hands more like it
strips your skin
i don't know why you're not even well
that's just your weak ass epidermis
apparently
it is it is my weak ass epidemic
because sometimes i love it when i can
feel my bone
yeah because some people have no some
people some people just have like really
sweaty hands and it feels like you know
that spray
that spray does nothing there's nothing
some people need [ __ ]
sweater your hands not my hands my hands
are like it's the one that you handshake
at a corn
you know it's it's the moist hand it's
the moisture you felt the moist hands
and for some reason the moist hand
always caught as [ __ ] it's
like you feel the moistness and you're
literally a cold wet fish
that's what it feels like that's what it
feels like it's like a dead fish right
it's like going to a supermarket and
like seeing one of those fish in the
fish it's actually just grabbing it
that's what it feels like
it is gross and you can never shake that
feeling off after it's like
off your hand yeah yeah yeah apologies
to anyone who has
cold wet hands but uh yeah
whoever's hand shaking their fish at
home shaking their fish
[ __ ] are we talking about yeah finding
nemo handshakes